[Music]
i'll let you in on a secret but i'm a
pretty big deal
real big deal
we are getting out of the city homer i
promise we'll go somewhere that loves
cats
no more fights
clean air
bright skies
[Music]
[Music]
oh
wait wait wait stop stop
whoa
[Music]
where on earth is this
passage
who's there and technically not earth
well no you would call this anyway i
swear to god [ __ ] show yourself show
myself i've shown where are you
right here at the end of your arm
oh hello yes
[Music]
okay so let me get this straight i'm
somewhere that's not what i would call
earth
i'm seeing a freaking dragon and oh yeah
i'm talking to a cop
did i just do that
wait i just moosed it with my freaking
mic
yeah okay that is something i do now i
do magic kill jacked up beats i'll
probably fly next
no you're just being ridiculous oh
that's too far good to know there's a
line
[Music]
our land suffers you are the only hope
we have you're special
you're the one that's planning on facing
off with sylar
tantasila is the strongest and most
formidable of all the taunters
you will be doing our land a great
service by killing her
[Music]
frey
no name for a demon
i am the one you seek the one and only
tant asylum
you